c'est presque au bout du bout de leur
mauvais ces sept oeuvres d'ozias leduc
peinte en 1921 c'est aussi le point de
départ est le titre de la nouvelle
exposition de nicolas partie aux jeunes
artistes incontournables à qui le musée
des beaux-arts donné carte blanche c'est
l'idée d'autres de crépuscule qui main
qui me touchait beaucoup et que je crois
que le côté très poétique de leur
mauvais fonctionnait très bien youcat
l'artiste suisse basée à new york a
puisé dans la vaste collection du musée
pour y sélectionner des oeuvres de
grands maîtres et les faire dialoguer
avec les siennes ce de pouvoir revoir en
fait des oeuvres du passé qui avait été
conçu de manière très différente est
justement de les voir de manière
anachronique pour voir comment nous
parle du temps présent du ton futur il a
complètement redécorer les salles du
pavillon michal et renata rhône sting et
le résultat est à couper le souffle une
fierté pour le directeur général du
musée stéphane aquin le tout fait
vraiment oeuvres d'art depuis le moment
où on arrive dans le grand escalier puis
on voit la murale on est dans une oeuvre
d'art de nicolas parti je caresse le
souvenir et pour ajouter à la magie
pierre lapointe signe la trame sonore de
larmor je me suis dit dans le fond je
vais faire exactement ce que nicolas
partie fixe je vais prendre une oeuvre
existant qui est un classique de la
chanson et je vais écrire une oeuvre
nouvelle originale en réaction à ces
ensuite pour le choix des pièces
originales j'ai bien étudié chacune des
salles que nicolas avait monté et j'ai
essayé de faire des choix en réponse les
deux artistes ont exploré le rapport
qu'entretiennent les créateurs avec la
nature à toutes les époques je me suis
rendu compte que comme dans l'histoire
de l'art pictural en histoire de la
musique où sion on a commencé à forger
l'identité québécoise à travers la
nature ce qui m'a marqué deux beaux
coups succès de cette forte présence en
fait de la représentation de nature et
de l'histoire en fait des relations des
artistes et de la culture canadienne
avec les paysages qui est un point qui
défend une relation et des alizés des
feux ne sont très conflictuels n'est que
la partie a réalisé sur place de grande
murale au pastel son matériau
prédilection c'est un peu comme des
êtres d'un papillon en fait cette
fragilité cette sensualité c'est ce que
je crois que ce qui me touche beaucoup
et qui m'attire mais que la partie a
commencé sa carrière comme graffeurs il
est habitué aux oeuvres éphémères en
octobre à la fin de l'exposition ces
oeuvres créées au musée disparaîtront
pour toujours il faut donc profiter de
toute cette beauté au moment c'est
encore l'heure leurs mots
[Musique]